let's just say your girlfriend goes out
for a couple of weeks
what do you do when you feel a
zinc a lustful feeling you must say
you're hungry you're hungry for some
human needs
[Music]
hi hi naya and michelle how old are you
i am 10. you're 10. so are you going
into
fifth grade yeah do you know who your
teacher is going to be this year
oh roger's starting already you started
already yeah how old are you ty
12 i like your tattoo which one my
neighbor told her you know my neighbor
totoro
my name is xiaowan i'm five years old
you're five when's your birthday
um i don't know so today i'm going to
talk to you about polyamory have you
ever heard about that before
no probably everything it's
where you like have either two
boyfriends or two girlfriends like that
or you have more
yeah that's pretty much it even if i
have a boyfriend or a girlfriend that
i'm open to the possibility of
connecting with somebody else what
dad husband or dad husband i don't get
it
like an example i like to give when i
talk about polyamory is
do you have a favorite food i like pizza
a lot i can't decide
you can't decide perfect example right
give me your top three favorite foods
can i give restaurants sure yeah in and
out chipotle
and chili's
okay awesome polyamory is saying great
it's amazing that you love all of those
restaurants and you probably love them
for all like different reasons right
whereas monogamy is like you can only
eat
in and out for the rest of your life and
you can never have another restaurant
again
i like that even though it's just food
it's food doesn't either have feelings
i feel like if you do get like let's say
two boyfriends
the other boyfriend would get jealous or
if you say the other one of it
the other boyfriend would get jealous
that's a really good point and that does
actually happen
i don't have to be equally in love with
everybody right
maybe you're at school and you want to
play with your best friend but then
maybe
the next day somebody who you've never
played with before invites you over to
the swing set
your best friend she might be jealous
but that doesn't mean that you don't
love her anymore that you don't want to
play with her ever again
so is it basically this shy
love hexagon or something sometimes that
works
for people in polyamorous relationships
like you might have three people who are
all in a relationship
together but what if he ends up catching
more feelings for her than you
yeah you're not good for me anymore me
and susie who i met last night which you
allowed me to date
yeah we're leaving bye that's absolutely
a possibility
everybody is allowed to follow their
heart in whatever way makes sense to
them so even though it would be
painful that my partner might have
stronger feelings for somebody else
i would want them to do whatever made
them happiest
all right i guess
what made you once a day and go freaky
freaky with everyone
it wasn't like a lightning bolt from god
and all of a sudden i knew
but it was like i want to allow myself
to be
as close to my like authentic not
boyfriend number available are you the
father take the dna test
nope okay boyfriend number sixty nine
thousand four hundred and twenty
are you the boyfriend no okay well
that's all of them
well for me personally if i'm going to
get pregnant it's going to be a very
intentional purposeful thing and at that
point i would probably just want to
focus on the one person that i would
want to have
a family with all right all right
does that make sense yeah
well thanks for your time bye bye bye
enjoy your free life bye
[Music]
hello hi nice to meet you nice to meet
you too
i'm evan nice to meet you hello evan so
how um
how's it going today like do you have
any thoughts on kind of like
monogamy or polyamory um
yeah i say monogamy's not bad monogamy's
not
why don't you think it's bad like it's
not bad
yeah like yeah it's good i am leaning
on the other side on being free
to choose and to have many partners
free to choose why why do you say that
because you just don't want to lock
yourself up with one person and say
bam that's your wife great now don't do
anything else you must only love her
and you must only be with her forever
that is intense do you have
a favorite disney princess
yes who is it um
i have lots of them like cinderella
ariel
though and they all have just one prince
just one prince yeah and that's kind of
what like
makes it so amazing is that like belle
finds her one prince it wouldn't really
be the same thing if belle had like
five princes
it would be silly how many girls have
you dated and how many
um times have you watched netflix and
killed with them
um
i've never met a person the other thing
the other like plot i don't know how to
say it do you think that it's
good that your parents are monogamous oh
yeah
do you think like your mom would like it
if your dad had
another girlfriend no high tens high
100s
you got you got to give me a ballpark
here man
more than two less than a hundred more
than two less than one hundred
all right do you like see these just in
movies and that's why you decide to be
monogamous or do you decide on your own
decision
that's a really great question there is
something about having like
one singular partner one person you can
truly depend on
that actually kind of help like
simplifies everything because
it's about that stability and about that
person who you know
no matter what happens in your life that
they will be there for you
50 less than 50
40 it's narrow enough three it's narrow
enough
okay are you bored one
with with one girlfriend no
because you know like my girlfriend's my
princess and just like beast never gets
bored of belle i never get bored of my
girlfriend
do you want to get married someday
that's if
i never get married at first i'm gonna
work on trying to get a girlfriend first
you said a girlfriend though yes like
one girlfriend
i have to work on getting one first
before i try to get more
let's just say i think you're gonna get
a girl so once you have this girlfriend
are you cool with like her having
another boyfriend
mm-hmm i was not gonna shoe school with
me having another girl you don't think
that like
you would feel jealous if she was like
kissing another dude well as long as she
doesn't feel jealous that i'm kissing
another girl
but i have to ask you a question sure if
mondoggity is
so great then how come the divorce rates
are
so high that's a really why are people
getting married just to say
you know it's over i i don't want to be
with you anymore take
take the dog okay i'm taking my son
i actually think that's a really great
question but like i think it's usually
way more complicated than that and
looking at people who have been divorced
like it's not
just because someone like wants another
partner there's like a lot of reasons
why people might get divorced
really yes is it really oh for sure
whoa what's your favorite food i don't
really have a favorite food man
name my favorite restaurant my favorite
restaurant is
tara at italy and i would eat there
seven days a week
if you were to only eat there just for
the rest of your life
you wouldn't no but people aren't
inanimate objects that provide calories
like food so i don't
question it's a metaphor dude it's a
it's a good metaphor
well to make a nutritious and full
circle meal
you have to have several things on it
correct
for some guidelines you must have your
grains which could be
a girlfriend you could have your
vegetables it could be another
girlfriend
and then 50 protein which could be your
wife
the other drink on the side could be
i don't know maybe another girlfriend it
takes
many pieces of the pie to create
one dish when it comes to food
that's true let's just say your
girlfriend goes out for a couple of
weeks
what do you do when you feel a
zinc a lustful feeling you must say
what do you do you're hungry you're
hungry for some human meat
absence makes the heart grow fonder i
would fast and then that meal would be
even more delicious once i finally had
it
but what if she is somewhere off getting
her human meat from someone else and
making a mukbang
video well assuming you don't literally
mean she's a cannibal because that would
no of course not that would prompt
someone i'm not savages here
you know i have a lot of confidence in
the nutrition that i provide
once you you go to the buffet and once
you like pick out
like you might get sick and then maybe
you'll change your mind but look
you haven't even had a girlfriend yet
okay monogamy doesn't mean
you only eat one thing to start it means
you try everything
and then you settle on your favorite
food anything else
that's all my questions i am satisfied
see
[Music]
thanks man
i almost made him break but we ran out
of time
[Music]
even though it's good to have more than
one person in your life
i feel like when you love someone you
just love that one person
[Music]
if you have a lot of
friends that's okay but for a boyfriend
um that will be
a little bit silly if you have a lot of
boyfriends
i am undecided because i choose both i
would rather
choose my pilots and taste other
different types of foods
and then settle on one what did you say
at the end there
and then settle on one one more time
settle
on one come on over ty hey that doesn't
mean that i still can't taste whether
it's foods when i'm having my entree
because it's kind of like eating yogurt
land when you're still eating you can
still sneak on over to the
to the side and add a little more to
your dish i can't cut this chair in half
so
i'll just put it right there do i have
two shoes aside
okay i'm ready
[Music]
oh here he comes
because why do i have to choose when i
can just do both
which i think that's technically
polyamory just saying
oh okay then i disagree i think that
it's monogamy it's like
dating and then settling on one you guys
sound like politicians
i'd rather end in a tie
but if you have five boyfriends on
valentine's day you would get
five boxes of chocolate
that's too much
i'll have a tummy ache
[Laughter]
i respect your choice and i think that
as you get older you're going to
see that you have the opportunity to
make whatever choices make you happy and
if monogamy makes you happy that's okay
and if polyamory makes you happy that's
okay too
i think something that's really
interesting is that like when i made my
arguments
i didn't have to really like explain
anything other
than point out like their parents and i
could reference
disney or anything else that just like
reinforces
monogamy and i and i did that and that
was you know manipulative and my
strategy but i think it's really
important to be just aware of
like how strong that influence
is thank you um regardless of where the
kids stand today i think it's important
for them
to know that an alternative to that
narrative
exists it's kind of like both sides are
like
yin and yang the chaos and the good
and the good and the chaos well said bye
bye see ya
hi everyone thank you for watching this
episode if you have
any suggestions for future topics please
leave them in the comment section below
also if there are any comments that are
directed towards the kids
i really hope that they're filled with
love and are words of encouragement
because at the end of the day they're
just kids and they also scroll through
comments thank you for watching this
video and i'll see you next time